[Music]
and hundreds of people are at the beach
soaking up the hot Summer Sun what's
that something catches your eye you look
up at the sky and see an Aurora people
around you start taking out their phones
to post a picture of the spectacle
suddenly everyone loses their phone
signal something strange is going on a
stream of solar particles is crashing
into the Earth's magnetic field at
speeds of up to 8 million km/h you might
want to be prepared because the worst is
yet to come
here's what you can do to survive a
solar storm a coronal mass ejection is a
massive burst of plasma and
electromagnetic radiation released from
the Sun the good news is that Earth's
magnetosphere and atmosphere shield us
from these dangerous particles but even
those solar storms can't hurt us
physically they can seriously affect our
technology
one of the most devastating solar flares
to hit Earth happened in 1859 the
Carrington event the radiation shocked
operators and set telegraph pylons on
fire today in the worst case scenario an
intense solar storm could overload our
electric grids sending our world into a
blackout so what can you do to prepare
for a solar storm why should you avoid
traveling during one and why might you
want to withdraw some cash from the bank
right now step 1 prepare ahead of time
the main threat you'll have to face
during a solar storm is a blackout that
means no electricity no communications
no internet and no social media you've
got a better chance of surviving a
blackout if you prepare beforehand have
the essential items you'd need for any
type of disaster Doomsday Preppers
recommend a 30-day supply of food and
water stock up on non perishable foods
like canned goods and dried foods since
your fridge won't be working each person
in your household will need about 4
liters of water each day now that you
have the necessities on hand for any
disaster what should you do when a solar
storm blackout happens and what if you
didn't prepare in advance step to save
your food grocery stores may run out of
food with the disruption of supply
chains and if you can't grow your own
food you'll have to save your food for
as long as possible if your water supply
is still working fill up your bathtub
and other containers with water keep
your fridge closed as much as you can
there won't be any electricity but that
should keep your food at a safe
temperature for about 4 hours your
freezer should stay cold for about 48
hours and don't forget to eat your
fruits
those are the foods that will spoil
first step 3
secure your house during the day find
and collect matches flashlights or any
other sources of light you wouldn't want
to be stuck in the dark and we wouldn't
recommend making a fire in your house
while you're searching make sure to lock
all the windows and doors keep your home
safe from intruders and burglars when
disaster strikes and reach out to your
neighbors see if there's anything you
can help them out with in tough times
like this they might not be prepared or
they might just need a friend to talk to
step 4 don't travel when a solar storm
strikes the last place you'd want to be
is up in the air being at a high
altitude can increase your risk of being
exposed to solar radiation not only that
but with satellite communications down
the planes navigation system won't work
planes could end up traveling in the
wrong direction and some might even
collide and don't even think about
riding the subway if you think that your
rush hour commute is horrible now
imagine what it would be like if the
system stops during a solar storm step 5
get some cash depending on how badly the
power grids are damaged it could take
years to repair them all if there's no
system in place to supply food and water
you might need money to buy some and
since there's no electricity to power
the ATMs and banks you'll only have the
money you have on hand break out that
piggy bank and crack open your swear jar
hopefully our communities won't plunge
into chaos and lead to an economic
collapse don't join that angry mob
we've got just the video to help you
move on to how to survive
[Music]